PROFESSOR: OK.
This video is a
different direction.
It will be about linear
equations and not differential
equations.
A matrix is at the
center of this video
and it's called the
incidence matrix.
And that incidence matrix tells
me everything about a graph.
Now, what do I mean
by the word graph?
I don't mean a graph
of sine x or cosine x.
The word graph is
used in another way
completely for some
edges and some nodes.
So I have some nodes.
In this case 1, 2, 3, 4 nodes.
That's my number n.
The number m is the number of
edges that connect the nodes.
So I have edge 1 connecting
those nodes, edge 2, edge 3, 4,
and 5.
And I didn't put in an edge 6.
A complete graph would
have all possible edges,
but a general graph
can have some edges.
Some pairs of
nodes are connected
others are not connected.
So now I want to create the
matrix that shows me everything
that's in that picture.
Then I can work with
the matrix and graphs.
And their matrices are the
number one application,
number one model for
so many applications,
like the world wide web.
The web might have-- every
website would be a node
and there would be an
edge between two nodes
if those websites are linked.
So the world wide
web is a giant graph.
Or the telephone company
has a giant graph
in which the nodes
are the telephones,
and there is an edge when a
call is made from one phone
to another, between two phones.
So, nodes and edges.
And our brain-- which
is the great problem
of the 21st century is to
understand the graph that
represents our brain, the
connections of neurons
in our thinking-- well, that's
a tougher problem than we'll
solve today.
Let me work with that graph
and create the matrix.
So the matrix has five rows
coming from the five edges.
Let me take the first edge.
So the first edge, there's
edge number 1, goes from node 1
to node 2.
The nodes correspond to columns.
So if I want an edge
from node 1 to node 2,
that edge 1 will go in row 1.
So edge 1.
First edge is
connected to row 1.
So that edge goes from node 1
to node 2, so I put a minus 1
and a 1.
And it doesn't
touch nodes 3 and 4.
That's edge 1.
That's row 1.
Now that tells me everything
I see about edge 1.
Edge 2 goes from 1 to 3.
So I'll put a minus 1,
a 0, and a 1 in row 2
because row 2 comes from edge
2 and it goes from 1 to 3.
Edge 3 will give me
row 3, from 2 to 3.
So edge 3 giving
me row 3, 2 to 3.
Edge 4 went from 1 to 4.
So minus 1, nothing, nothing, 1.
That tells me that edge 4 is
going from node 1 to node 4.
And finally, from node 2
to node 4 is the final row.
Do you see there the graph?
Everything, all the
information in this picture
is now captured in that matrix.
So we can work with the matrix.
And what does a matrix do?
It multiplies vectors.
That's what a matrix
does, it acts on vectors.
So what happens if I multiply
that matrix by a vector?
So now let me take
out these edge numbers
and do a multiplication.
That matrix has four columns,
it's a 5 by 4 matrix, m by n.
5 by 4.
So it multiplies a vector with
four components and those four
components will come
from the four nodes.
And maybe they represent
voltages at the nodes.
Let me think like an electrical
engineer for a moment.
So if there's my
matrix, I imagine
I have voltages, v1, v2,
v3, v4, at the nodes.
So there's a v1 voltage
here, v2, a v3, and a v4,
and where those voltages'
currents will flow.
So my unknowns are the
voltages, the four voltages,
and the five currents.
That's what the
engineer needs to know.
So first of all, when I multiply
A times v, what do I get?
Let me just do that
multiplication.
So that first row times that
gives me v2 minus v1, right?
The dot product of the
row with the vector.
The next one is v3 minus v1.
Then I have a minus 1 there.
It's a v3 minus a v2.
Then I have a minus 1 and a 1.
I think that's v4 minus v1.
And finally, this
dot product of that
will give me a v4 minus v2.
So what am I seeing here?
This is now A times v.
I've done a multiplication
by a vector of voltages.
And what have I found?
I found the differences
in voltages,
the voltage difference
between one end
of the edge and the other one.
I have five edges and
now I have five results
and those are the
voltage differences.
And what does a
difference in voltage
do if these are at different
voltages, different potentials?
Current flows.
If they're at the same
potential, no current flows,
right?
That's the fundamental
driving equation
of currents from voltages is
the difference in the voltage.
The difference in the
potential drives the flow.
And now, how much flow?
So now I'm looking
for the flows.
So can I call those
w, for the flows.
So I have a w2 is the
flow on that edge.
A w1 is a flow there.
A w5, a w3, and a w4.
My pair of unknowns-- and that's
the beauty of this picture--
is the voltages v1 to v4 four
at the nodes, and the currents,
the flows, w1 to w5
on the five edges.
And I've seen that Av gives
me the voltage differences.
I'm going to briefly,
briefly approach
the fundamental laws of
flow, of current flow,
of flow in any network.
We're talking about the
most basic equation,
I would almost say, of
applied mathematics.
Maybe I should say of
discrete applied mathematics.
By discrete I mean a
graph without derivatives.
I'm not seeing
derivatives here, I'm just
seeing matrices and vectors.
So I have to remember
that incidence matrix,
A-- let me write it down again.
Av gave the voltage differences.
And that's one
part of my picture.
Another part is what is the
equation that finally brings it
together?
That if I have the currents--
so the v's were the voltages.
Now, there's going to
be an equation involving
w, the currents.
This, what I'm
going to write here,
is going to be really important.
It's going to be Kirchhoff's
Current Law, KCL.
And I just emphasized that there
are two Hs in Kirchhoff's name.
So Kirchhoff's
Current Law says--
and pay attention-- it says
that the total flow into a node
equals the flow out.
We're talking about
equilibrium here.
So if current is traveling
around my graph, my network,
and it's a stable equilibrium
here so that flow into node 1
equals flow out of node 1.
And let me tell you
what that equation is
in terms of the matrix A.
This voltage difference
is involved A
and, beautifully, the
Kirchhoff's Current Law
involves A transpose.
So A transpose now is 4 by 5.
These are the flows, a
vector with five components
because I have five edges.
And Kirchhoff's Current
Law would say that's 0.
So between A and A transpose,
the incidence matrix
is leading me to the fundamental
equilibrium condition
for flow in a network.
Now, one more law is needed.
It has to connect voltage
differences to flows,
potentials to currents.
Do you know who created that
law in electrical engineering?
It was Ohm.
So Ohm's Law, finally,
Ohm's Law is edge by edge
that the potential difference,
the drop in potential,
the potential forcing current
is proportional to the current.
So voltage difference--
let me write it in words.
Voltage difference--
voltage drop
I could say-- between the
ends or across a resistor
is proportional to, and
there is some resistance,
some physical number
comes in here.
This is where the material
we're working with comes in.
In Kirchhoff's Laws, those
laws hold for a network
before we even say what
the network is made of.
But now if our network is
made of resistors or pipes
or whatever we have, then
this will be some conductance.
So E equal IR, some resistance,
times the flow, times
the current flow, w.
So a difference in
v's is some number,
this is the physical
constant that we
have to measure in a lab to know
how many ohms our resistor is.
That equation is on each edge.
So we have a bunch of
equations and together they
tell us the four voltages
and the five currents.
And maybe I'll just make
the main point here.
The main point is that
this matrix is crucial.
A is crucial.
A transpose is crucial.
A gives voltage differences,
it makes something happen.
A transpose is the balance law,
the balance or current balance
at each node.
And you won't be surprised
that when the whole thing is
put together and we have
a final equation to solve,
we end up with A
transpose and A.
And that magic
combination, A transpose A,
is central to graph theory.
It's called the graph
Laplacian and has
a name and a fame of its own.
Thank you.